now to the new Fallout from the deadly
police shooting of a Texas woman last
Friday we have to warn you here that the
body cam video of this encounter is very
tough to watch the three San Antonio
officers involved are facing murder
charges Melissa Perez was said to be
suffering a mental health crisis when
police opened fire at her home Omar via
Franca spoke to one of her children as a
family now plans to follow a civil suit
against the officers
I have not slept it was 24 year old
Alexis Tovar who had to break the news
to her three younger brothers after
their mother Melissa Perez was shot dead
in her home by police of course they
just broke down
baby the nine-year-old of course
he didn't know what to do
like as a nine-year-old how do you
how do you take this in you know
hey body cam video edited by police
shows Perez talking with officers early
Friday morning after getting a call
saying she was cutting wires to her
apartment complex's alarm system the
family attorney says she was having a
mental health crisis she was cutting the
wires because she thought the FBI was
listening to her get over here Perez ran
back inside her home where officers
jumped onto her patio tried to remove
her window screen while calling for her
to come out you're gonna get shot
she then threw a glass candle holder at
one officer
and after what police say was 30 minutes
of communicating with her Perez then
swung a hammer toward me
that's when one officer shot at her but
missed when Perez continued to approach
them with the hammer three officers
opened fire
the 46 year old was pronounced dead at
the scene the three officers involved
were arrested and released on bail
they've been suspended without pay as
they face murder charges do you see bad
protocol or bad policing both instead of
de-escalating it was you're gonna get
shot tovarp who was studying to be a
nurse is now tasked with caring for her
grieving family that's he planned my
mom's funeral my mom didn't deserve to
die like that
the police department and the Bear
County D.A are both conducting their own
investigations the family tells me they
plan to file a little a civil lawsuit
very soon and in addition to Alexis
Perez Left Behind three other children
ages 15 13 and 9. Tony
it's a tough interview there Omar thank
you very much regardless what happens in
the in the in the court case in the
legal process I'm sure that video will
be used in training because I don't
think anyone agrees that that's the
outcome anyone wanted I think even
fellow police officials are saying they
don't think the protocol was followed I
realized she had a hammer I get that but
just seems like there was another way
that you could have handled that
situation but we weren't there we
weren't there I'm thinking about those
children that's what I keep thinking
about you like the news to those young
children uh
the other part of the interview uh the
daughter says I wish they would have
just talked to her and figured out a way
to de-escalate the situation there seems
to be more of that is needed in these
cases or maybe cops are not the ones
called the mental health uh calls but
we'll see lots to talk about there